there wouldn't be much point to a job
search solution without jobs to search
for in our last video we talked about
creating companies using the Google
cloud talent solution job search API now
let's talk about how to create jobs and
best practices for working with them
[Music]
we'll get started by creating a job you
can't make a job without a company so
we'll be using a company that we created
in the last video there are also a few
required fields we'll need first off
we'll need the company's name which is
the unique identifier not to be confused
with the display name will also need a
requisition ID which is a string that
represents your own unique identifier
for the job kind of like external ID for
companies this is helpful to make sure
it's easier to sync the job search API
and your current job solution there's
also the title which is well the display
title of the job description is where
you put all the job details and related
information you can use HTML and some
markup tags here finally we'll need at
least one of three fields under
application info you our eyes emails or
instruction these help point jobseekers
to where they'll need to go in order to
apply URIs and emails our arrays in case
you have multiple while instruction is
an HTML friendly string where you can
describe the application process each
job could have all three but you can't
create a job without having at least one
with all those fields you can create a
job so let's look at some code the code
structure should look pretty similar to
our other samples but let's walk through
the bits to create the job we need to
include the project ID and the company
name here so we can use it when we first
define the job well hard code it just
for this snippet here we're passing in
the job when we call the API with jobs
create again pretty simpler to creating
a company and here's where we actually
define the job and set those required
fields we've got the company name which
was set up above as well as the
requisition ID which is the string we
can use to more easily map the job to
our job system after that there's the
title description and in this case we
provided a link for the application
information so from here we'll create
the job and the API knows which company
it belongs to this is we pass in the
company name after running that code
here's part of the response we'll see
the new job was created and it has the
same property values that we passed in
as well as a unique name that we can use
when referencing a job now that we can
create jobs what happens when we try to
create a job that's already in the
system as you might expect you'll get an
error because job duplicates aren't
allowed duplicates are determined by
three fields company name requisition ID
and language code we provided company
name and requisition ID when creating
the job language code is an optional
field that will represent the language
based on the job description and it
defaults to en-us if not set as long as
the combination of these three fields is
unique the job won't be treated as a
duplicate so that's the basics for
creating jobs we can also get a job to
see the details delete a job to get rid
of it and patch a job to update any
properties just like companies you
should pass in an update mask which is a
string of comma-separated properties
that you want to update there's a few
more details about why that's important
in the company's video we can also list
jobs to see all the jobs in the system
this is just a simple list without any
filtering so it's probably better saved
for any administrative functionality
this code is the modified version of our
list company's code that now shows
companies and jobs will loop through
each company and then list jobs for that
company by filtering on the company's
name pretty simple but a great starting
point to making sure that you know the
jobs and companies in your system
there's quite a few more fields when
dealing with jobs but they're optional
let's look at some of the more common
ones and you can always check on the
docs to see the full list each job can
have an array of up to 50 addresses
which are passed in as strings just like
companies the API will create a
read-only property for each job called
derived info that looks at addresses you
pass in as well as the parent company's
information to geolocate each job this
is all powered by the Google Maps
geocoding API so if it works there it'll
work here
there's also posting region which lets
you specify how strict the location
matching for the job needs to be for
instance if the posting region is set to
nation this job will show up in Ferriss
search and jobs that match the same
country administrative area depends on
the country but represents areas like
States for United States and Prefecture
for Japan telecommute means the job
allows for remote work and the location
is less relevant
there are also some fields to help you
talk more about the job itself such as
job benefits compensation info
employment types and degree types each
of these have their own object or enum
to get the most accurate data but
they're all pretty simple fields
there's even custom attributes so you
can provide your own key value pairs and
do some advanced searching which we'll
talk about in a later video however
these are all useful to help job
searchers get better results there are
also a few properties specific to the
job posting itself these are all strings
that represent time stamps the fields
posting create time and posting update
time are read-only fields that let you
know when the job posting was created
and most recently updated respectively
jobs start time and job end time are
useful for contracting or seasonal jobs
where you might have specific timing
requirements posting published time
represents when this job was most
recently published while posting expire
time is the time stamp for when the job
posting expires by default the
expiration time is set to 30 days after
the job was created we definitely
recommend explicitly setting the
expiration date to what makes the most
sense for your business for example if
you update a job but don't include a new
expiration time it'll refresh the
expiration to 30 days from the time of
the update if you want to get around
that explicitly set a new expiration
time or make sure to use an update mask
without posting expire time expired jobs
won't show up in search results or when
calling lists but you can still get the
properties of an expired job by using it
and in fact update it with patch it's
even possible to update the posting
expire time to unexpired a job that
patch may fail if there's another open
job with the same company name
requisition ID and language code so make
sure that you handle any errors that
come back also if the job is expired for
long enough or you have too many expired
jobs compared to open jobs expired jobs
start to get permanently deleted
remember the job search API is a search
index for jobs so if you want any
permanent record-keeping you should do
that in the job solution directly that's
a brief overview to help you start
loading companies and jobs with all that
data there's only one thing to talk
about in our next video performing
searches thanks for watching and
remember when looking for talent it's
okay to keep your head in the cloud
[Music]
[Music]